[Musique]
oui mais ma parole à des femmes
s'immiscent au volant depuis sept
semaines je veux vous parler de
sexualité mais pas pour parler
nécessairement du sujet d'actualité
c'est à dire le convoi des camions man
qui sont en train de se mobiliser pour
aller jusqu'à ta voix pour manifester
contre les passeports et n'a aucune
obligation vaccinale qui pourrait leur
être imposée parce que ce sont des
camionneurs transfrontalier etats unis
canada donc un gros convoi mais c'est
pas le sujet des vaccins sont pas le
sujet du convoi en tant que tel qui
mobilise la chronique c'est
l'utilisation de l'image de la voix et
même des fois de la présence des
communautés autochtones lors de ces
manifestations
pourquoi est-ce que je parle c'est parce
qu'il ya eu un appui qui existent de
certains membres des communautés de
caunes avait partout ça peut être des
petits groupes comme des grands groupes
qui appuient le convoi pour différentes
raisons diction pour appuyer les
camionneurs tout ça pour appuyer
je devrai tout la mobilisation contre
les mandats vaccinaux tout le monde a
son opinion personnelle ou sur les
pignons comme une auberge
c'est comme n'importe quelle communauté
à travers le canada il y a des gens qui
ont débordé combes et je sais pas mais
les problématiques
non je veux parler c'est l'utilisation
de ces images mais des fois des images
qui ne sont pas autorisés ou des images
sont faussement interprétées de hambourg
est parfaite la voix des communautés
autochtones pour donner du poids à une
mobilisation qui ne conserve pas ou qui
n'a pas demandé
je marchais voilà d'être utilisé deux
des instances qui ont motivé ma
chronique c'est premièrement une c'est
l'utilisation d'un vidéo qui donnerait
de 2018 2019 nous on voit des chanteurs
des drames qui font une danse en cercle
et les vidéos qui est utilisée que et
partager quand même énormément ses
réseaux sociaux dili communauté
autochtone nous et puis ils sont avec
nous dans le convoi est la personne qui
avait fait les vidéos beaucoup de
membres des communautés aussi qui ont
des membres de leur famille dans cette
vidéo le redis c'est faux ces vidéos
leur défaite pour telle raison c'était
dans un contexte donc à retirer les
vidéos arrêter de dire que c'est parce
que vous appliquez en fait cette
danseuse pour vous c'est font donc
première instance où on voit une
problématique de l'utilisation de
l'image de formation des communautés
nous mêmes mais interprétation de
l'activité qu'on voit dans une vidéo
deuxième événement c était un tweet où
on peut voir devant un grand camion
une affiche qui dit que tu nommes
justement certains des sites où on a
découvert le corps des enfants des
pensionnats et s'était mis à la vente
d'un grand camion qui fait partie du
convoi c'est donc des images qui utilise
beaucoup les enjeux de colle les voies
vertes donne des images octobre et
pourquoi est-ce que c'est problématique
c'est que présentement dans la
mobilisation qui ce qui se passe il ya
beaucoup de vos actions diverses
sections l'ultime donc qui viennent de
différents
d'idéologie mais un des enjeux qui t'a
mis de l'avant par beaucoup de mobiliser
des personnes des militants autochtones
aussi c'est que certaines parties de ses
convois le sont aussi financer supportée
par d'ego qui ont des mandats anti
d'accès des mandats qui sont aussi
mélangé avec de l'extrême droite qui ont
des messages racistes ou de suprématie
blanche donc tout se mélange 2 amène une
confusion par rapport à quai ce qui est
vraiment me l'as monaco convoi de
camions man et comment la voix
d'internautes et autochtone est utilisée
ou instrumentalisés dans ce cas aussi et
désaccords qui en viennent parce qu'il
faut comprendre que qu'on parle de
mobilisation pactole comme on a pu le
voir en 2012 avait à un moment on
sentait qu un message comme une offense
à dire qu' un message commun comme nous
qui est mis de l'avant pour pouvoir
faire avancer une cause qui nous est
commune malgré nos idéaux légitime et
comment je m'explique c'est lors de la
même mobilisation et donneront une vie
des gens qui étaient à l'automne des
gens on tâtonne avait des gens qui ne
les communautés urbaines vie commune aux
op
qu'on appelle des réserves et des
membres qui venait des groupes
politiques que ceux des groupes
politiques de tous les groupes
politiques à l'opt out au canadien donc
toutes les voix se mélangent et 2b le
message commun était vraiment de faire
entendre la voix des communautés spector
et malgré que certains groupes ont
essayé aussi de s'approprier la voix
l'ensemble du noyau de la voie des
grandes voix a été entendue et des
porteurs tous ensemble malgré nos
divergences d'opinion sur 12 d'autres
enjeux entente on peut le voir aussi des
fois dans la mobilisation
environnementales ou protéger la planète
mais pour plein de raisons différentes
parce qu'on a des visions sur la
protection des animaux la protection des
forêts la protection des territoires
pour pouvoir permettre de mire
électrification vraiment des
ddv plusieurs zones sont portés mais
dans un message complet présentant ce
message comment est moins clair avec le
convoi et utilise parfois justement une
espèce d'unités de beauté qui venait des
mobilisations d'octobre des dents sont
certes des chants du fait pour reprendre
notre voie pour être sur la place
publique ce qui nous habite et l'ont
empêché pour pouvoir se mobiliser autour
de ces dangereux donc la problématique
vient souvent sur soi
l'instrumentalisation des voitures comme
la toque émises à sion spécialisation
qui veut dire qu'on prend l'image de tom
et on en faire un token et pourquoi est
ce que la décolonisation c'est une
problématique c'est que c'est pas la
première fois en mobilisation qu'on peut
le voir des fois c'est de mettre les
groupes autochtones à l'avant de la
marche qui s'est un peu de boucliers
on se croisait idéologique parce qu'on
voit cette énergie et c'est beau
si c'est fait pour être utilisés comme
boucliers des régies c'est une chose
s'il y a une discussion avec un groupe
qu une gamme tant est qu'on dit aux
médias des programmations de l'avant
pour leur permettre d'avoir la
visibilité et les côtes qu'ils ont
besoin depuis des décennies c'est tout
un autre enjeu dans le cas présent
beaucoup de connaux d'acton bons appuis
le convoi mais beaucoup s'y disent on
veut pas que nos voix soient utilisés
pour faire avancer des idéologies de
groupes d'extrême droite utilisés dont
plateforme utiliser d'autres méthodes
peut-être que le moment présent c'est
pour eux de se rassembler ensemble de se
dire ok peut-être qui sait passer un
message sommes pas prêts de convoyer
avec ce qu'on voit des fois même on va
dire et c seront insérés crée la peur
d'être sens en mettant le message est
peu clair il ya des gens qui participent
à l'intérieur de ces mobilisations le
qui ne savent pas non plus que ce
message importés dont ils deviennent un
peu
ce que m'ont dit les cheval de troie ou
même les porteurs du message parce
qu'ils ont leur idéologie qui veulent
avoir à supporter les camionneurs
empêcher justement la perte de droits
civils mais des groupes vont dans les
coulisses eu à mener mon message et
certaines personnes ont l'impression que
ce message de sa veille pour pouvoir
ensuite sortir du cheval de troie et
faire un grand coup d'éclat et à mener
de l'avant sa propre vision donc c'est
pour ça c'est problématique c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on garde à l'oeil les
mobilisations qui disait mon des
communautés autochtones on l'a vu aussi
dernièrement dans les dernières années
ou lcd fois par exemple le drapeau des
warriors apparaissent alors dans
mobilisation vecteur de mobilisation à
l'automne et là on demanderait héros et
les communautés autochtones et son pour
ça j'ai dit non ce sont des individus
porteurs de la peau qui porte deux
idéologies en or 2 mais est ce que vous
voyez la communauté là c'est comme une
ode est absent c'est qu'un problème il
faut pas oublier non plus que
présentement il ya un sentiment et non
de l'incapacité d'agir la capacité de
sortir de la main et tout ce qui peut
nous donner un sens de pouvoir prendre
les décisions en tant que citoyen face à
un gouvernement vont peut-être des fois
surpassé justement ce premier réflexe
est déjà en vente en un mot de regarder
qu'est-ce qui est derrière jda lancé
pour voir à tester le danger et on n'a
pas eu le temps de se rassembler de
s'unir et le comprendre le message pour
me porter c'est très important parce
qu'on l'a vu par le passé que
la parole de tonnes souvent été aussi
des vues comme une parure qui disait la
vérité qui inquiétait à mener de façon
non violente dont il y avait quand même
une grand sentiment de confiance d'un
rapport à ces les premières nations les
communautés comme apporte comme des
sages quand il décide de le faire un
grand groupe alors c'est à dire sans
avoir faim garder l'oeil ouvert faut
boire aussi que des vidéos ou des
messages peut être
content comment je voudrais construit
pour pouvoir fait d'autres messages
quand le message termes en étaient pas
le même temps on parle de fausses
nouvelles de fait news mais ça peut
aller dans les deux sens donc attention
vidéo vous partagez regarder toujours
les sources d'efforts gare d'où sont les
origines d'ailleurs une des premiers des
premiers grands pas que j'ai vu ce sont
ces vidéos le c'est ça d'avoir la
pandémie personnes en masse et sa
sainteté un guide pour pouvoir retrouver
les personnes à l'origine vidéo qui
demandent justement à une personne qui a
posté que c'est un faux message de
descendre de dollars c'est pas à lui de
l'utiliser que c'est pas lui des ventes
et un message autour de ce bien sûr pas
tout le monde écoute et messages
continuent de circuler avec la vidéo qui
n'a pas été accepté de partager
plus des semaines j'espère justement
qu'on continue sur ces enjeux de cette
discussion le beaucoup de points de vue
beaucoup de manières de vivre ensemble
mais un besoin de se comprendre et 230
justement qu'on décide d'avancer en
société c'est une belle semaine